are you going are you going to pop out
of somewhere and scare me I'm very
fortunate that I have a wife who loves
these things and gets excited by really
little things baby i wanna show you
something that's very very interesting
home very brightly excited it's raining
okay well Nina's doing that this is
Nina's new greenhouse by the way
everybody I want to see Lena's all
excited he's a cucumber I was moving to
step out to plan to get some ring water
and then I saw this time so why just
can't bend so I want to move it but then
I stopped this little vine is that she
viral around the meadow I was thinking
when it's when it's go bigger I'm gonna
we're gonna get a stick so the m the
plaque does the cucumber wall will
spiral round distinct but it's fair or
unfair this metal here that makes
exciting okay that's it that's what
you're so excited about yeah this is
what she's all excited about last week
we've hated see it it's sprouting what
is that beans beans okay ready last week
I'm very fortunate gotta have a wife who
loves these things it gets excited by
really little things and at some point
I'm sure all of these plants will turn
into food that we can enjoy eat I'm
gonna kiss the other one is
it has device coming I'm gonna get it
fake okay should we sign off Nina's very
excited anything we'll look at the plant
excites Nina okay bye believe happy
stick hunting